Hi everyone I'm Abbey from Abbey's kitchen. Welcome back to our series enlightened
by intuitive eating. In our last video, we
discussed principle four of intuitive
eating: challenge the food police. So if
you haven't watched that video, go back
and check it out by clicking the link
right here and then come back to watch
this one. Also a big thank you to Alyssa
Rumsey intuitive eating dietitian for
reviewing this content. I'm gonna be
leaving her contact information in the
description so you can easily reach out
to her for some one-on-one support. Now
before we get started, I wanted to flag
that this content may not be for all of
my viewers so feel free to take and
leave whatever you find valuable. Also
don't forget to follow the intuitive
eating journey along with me through
Evelyn Tribole and Elyse Resch's book,
which I'm going to be linking in the
description below. Ok let's get into a
reader question. Dear Abbey, I have celiac
disease which means that I have to avoid
all gluten containing products. If I have
even the tiniest bit of gluten, it can
cause a lot of damage to my GI tract. I'm
having a hard time balancing this with
intuitive eating and also the judgment
of others who think that this is a fad.
Any advice? This is such a popular and
important question. Now, let's be real the
diet industry has done a great job at
co-opting medically necessary dietary
restrictions into trendy ways to eat, but
for a lot of people with food
intolerances and allergies this is just
not another fad. In the case of celiac
disease, specifically, gluten actually
damages the GI tract and destroys micro
villi which can lead to poor nutrient
absorption. Therefore, avoiding gluten is
necessary for good health. But whether
we're talking about celiac disease, a
food allergy, or a food sensitivity or
intolerance, only you know what foods
immediately make you feel good or bad.
And part of eating intuitively is
listening very carefully to your body,
then gathering data about how foods make
you feel and making choices based on
that data. Just like I mentioned in my
previous intuitive eating video where I
talked about veganism and intuitive
eating, for some people who have really
dangerous symptoms and experiences from eating a particular food, you may in fact
feel that this food is just simply
inedible. So gluten containing bread
might just be not seen as food
or edible to a person with celiac
disease. In other cases where perhaps the
reaction is less severe, you may
occasionally decide that a piece of cake
is worth the physical symptoms even
though the data you've collected says
"hey I get diarrhea when I eat ice cream".
Eating ice cream wouldn't be failing at
intuitive eating. The key is to move on
without any guilt, shame, or insisting on
restricting or punishing yourself as a
result. If you're finding that your
dietary restrictions are getting in the
way of you finding food freedom, start by
reframing how you think about the
offending food and ensuring that there's
always tasty alternatives that you can
enjoy. So instead of saying "I can't have
bread" try saying "I choose to eat foods
that make me feel good which excludes
gluten filled bread but I can have this
amazing gluten free croissant". Try to
direct your attention towards all the
amazing food options that you do have
rather than the few items that are
inedible to you. By doing this, you're
choosing foods that you enjoy and that
feel good to your body - two really
important elements of intuitive eating.
Finally, if you're dealing with comments
from others about your dietary
restrictions it's important to really
address them. Sometimes it's as simple as
explaining to the person that you have a
food allergy or food intolerance and
that, although you have to avoid certain
foods, you openly eat many other ones. For
other people, you may have to be a bit
more upfront and advocate for your
health. Remember only you are the expert
in your body. Okay so on that note, let's
move on to the video. So in today's video,
we're gonna be discussing principle
number five - feel your fullness. Now growing up Im
sure a lot of you had parents that told
you to clean your plate before you could
leave the table. As a fellow parent now,
I'm sure the intentions were in the
right place and they simply just want to
prevent food waste or ensure that you
were well nourished so that you didn't
wake up a 3 am really super hungry. But
here's the thing, forcing any kid to
finish their plate can teach a child to
override their innate hunger cues and,
overtime, children learned that the way
to know that they're done eating is
something when their plate is empty not
when their body tells them. As they reach
adulthood, they bring this mentality with
them. Only now they've got free access to
a wide range of highly palatable
processed foods everywhere they go and
disposable income to purchase them.
Now, think about a family size bag of chips
and how easy it is to polish that bag
off when binge watching your favorite
show.
First, eating distracted can muffle your
fullness cues. Second, you subconsciously
finish the bag because you're "done" when
the bag is done. Now another example is
when you're satisfied from eating your
post dinner cookie treat but you notice
that there's one or two cookies left in
the package so you eat them to finish
off the pack. The "clean your plate"
mentality can be a huge reason why you
may be overeating without even knowing
it. But I can hear you thinking "but Abbey,
if I don't eat all the food on my plate
aren't I restricting food?" the answer is
simple - no. As an intuitive eater, you
allow all foods in your diet with no
explicit rules or limitations. You want
the cookie? You have permission to have
the cookie. You want a salad? You have
permission to have a salad. So if you
have a plate of food and you're full
before it's all finished, you know that
you always can enjoy that food another
time. You can put the rest in the fridge
for leftovers and have it another time.
It's not gone forever, and tomorrow will
be another delicious day. But if you
restrict foods to only special occasions,
like cheat days let's say, your favorite
five layer lasagna, you are going to want
to lick that plate clean because you
know that you only get it every blue
moon. You have now placed this food under a special category and because of that
you're less likely to listen to your
hunger cues and go overboard. But if you
knew that this food is available later,
let's say you know you put some away as
leftovers,
it's easy to stop eating when you've
reached fullness because you know you
can enjoy it again later.
Having said that, sometimes I get that a
really, really, special dish can only be
enjoyed in social occasions because, I
don't know, maybe someone special makes
it for you or you're in a really special
restaurant for your birthday. Sometimes
you're just going to overeat. The key
here is to not punish yourself by
restricting calories or exercising more
to "undo the damage". Hey, ate a lot of
lasagna, it's not a big deal. If you're
listening intently to your body, maybe
you won't be hungry for a big breakfast the next day,
or maybe you will notice these things
but don't judge yourself and simply move
on. Now, unfortunately because of this
clean plate mentality a lot of people
struggle to know what comfortable
satiety feels like. This is the point at
which you've satisfied your hunger but
you're not so full that you're
uncomfortable. You don't want anymore
food but if you had another bite you'll
be bursting at the seams. The point at
which a person achieves this is
obviously different from person to
person. Some people feel it really
quickly and easily, while others take a
little while and simply need more time.
It's really based on a person's hunger,
their needs, and what their body wants at
that time. So don't compare your plate to
another person's. To undo the "clean plate
mentality", you're gonna have to work on
this for a little bit of time. You need
to find a way to get away from the idea
that you're done eating when there's no
more food available. To do this, I want
you to try being on high alert when
eating, take notice of every bite, every
flavor, every texture. By becoming hyper
aware of the act of eating, you're
putting your attention on the experience
of eating instead of the external
indicators of what your plate looks like.
Over time, this process may help you slow
down and you'll start paying attention
to the gradual shift from being hungry
to being satisfied. According to Evelyn
Tribole and Elyse Resch, the writers of
intuitive eating, this is called
"conscious eating". If we go back to our
last video on principle number four
"challenging the food police",
you remember that I mentioned the food
anthropologist. This is a neutral voice
that observes and makes notes, no
judgement takes place.
So during conscious eating, I really want
you to welcome in the food
anthropologist. Now let's go through the
phases of eating with the food
anthropologist by our side starting with
the time during the meal or snack. While
you're eating, I want you to take a
second every few bites, maybe put your
knife and fork down finish chewing, and
just pause. This isn't a welcome
invitation to stop eating, it's just a
pause. Now I want you to check in with
yourself and notice the following.
Taste - how does the food taste? Do you like it? Are you only eating it because it's
available and in front of you? Really check in with how
pleasurable eating that food is for you.
Satiety - check in with how hungry you
really are. Are you satisfying your
hunger by eating this food? Is your
hunger going away? At the beginning of the
meal, this may not be very obvious.
Throughout the meal, you may want to do a
few of these satiety check-ins. Keep in
mind that you may not notice your
satiety levels change at all. I mean from
years of dieting, it can take many, many,
many, meals and a lot of practice before
you start to clue in. Just like you may
not get to know a person very well after
one dinner date, you may not know your
satiety cues after one meal or day
either. Now let's talk about what happens
when you're done eating. Now regardless
of how much food you ate, I want you to
take a non-judgmental observation. Ask
yourself - am I still hungry? Am I
satisfied? Am I really full? On a scale, I
want you to rate your fullness. Zero to
three would be like ravenously hungry,
four to five is pretty hungry, six to
seven is satisfied, eight is full, nine is
stuffed, ten is sick. Now most people feel
comfortable around a six or seven.
You know when you're satisfied and not
really hungry
but you're not so full that you're
feeling unwell. So, again, if you go over
seven you're not failing, so do not let
this turn into the hunger fullness diet.
Every meal and every person is so
different that your needs are always
going to ebb and flow depending on where you land at each meal. Sometimes you're gonna eat to
just a four and you're gonna need to eat
sooner after, and sometimes you're gonna
eat to a full-on 10 and maybe you'll be
satisfied for the rest of the day. This
is just data to help you correlate how
you feel and what you find comfortable
as patterns in how you eat, not to serve
as another impossible measuring stick to
beat yourself down with. Just like we did
during principle number two, I want you
to check in with your hunger before you
eat and then check in with your fullness
when you're done. Interestingly,
oftentimes, the hungrier you are when you
start eating the more likely you are to
feel overly full, stuffed, or even sick
when you're done. This is why principle
two "honour your hunger" comes first
because it's going to be really hard to
stop
eating when you're full if you aren't
honoring each and every one of those
body's hunger cues. Honoring your hunger
by eating whenever you are hungry helps
to build back body trust and makes it
easier for you to stop when you're full
because your body trusts that whenever
you're hungry again
you're gonna eat again. That is just data
to help you make decisions in the future
about when it feels best to start eating
and later stop. Now I want to make
something very clear, you do not have to
leave food on your plate. If you're still
hungry, by all means of course eat
until you're satisfied, clear your plate,
add more to your plate. The idea here is
that you're listening to your body, not
the appearance of the food on your plate.
Although you now know how to identify
fullness, you may still be wondering "what
if I don't notice these signs?" and truth
be told, that is totally normal.
A lot of people have lost the art of
this from years and years of dieting, but
the key here is to learn how to increase
your eating consciousness with the
following very important steps. Number
one -  limit distractions. I'm a mom,
multitasking is legitimately my middle
name. But parents or otherwise, you know,
we live in a society where we are
praised for being able to do a lot in a
little amount of time. We eat breakfast while
watching the news, we work at our desk
while eating lunch, and despite the
notion that we can multitask we actually
aren't as good as it as we might think.
In fact, when you multitask research
suggests that you're dividing your
brain's resources and attention,
resulting in less efficient work. Sure
you can do it but not to the same degree
as if you were to do each of those tasks
one by one. So if you're trying to become
an intuitive eater, you really need to
invest the time and effort into doing it.
Start by limiting distractions around
you. So turn the TV off, put your work
away, really focus on the act of eating
in a distraction-free environment. If you
have different things taking up your
attention, your attention is no longer
focused on listening to your body's
hunger and fullness cues. This is not
about setting rigid rules or you can
never watch TV and eat food at the same
time, but it's a good idea to test this
out to see if you find more pleasure in
eating when you're not so distracted.
You might be surprised how much more flavorful and
enjoyable food is when you've got your
full attention on it.
Number two - reinforce your conscious
decision to stop. It's easy to tell
ourselves "okay you're done eating". It's
another to actually stop eating. One
useful trick is to give yourself a
visual cue that you're done eating.
Remember you're done eating when you're
satisfied, not when you feel like you
should be done. So for example, when
you're done with your meal you can put
your napkin on top of your plate. That
simple barrier between you and the food
can actually work wonders. It reminds you
that you consciously decided that you're
done and if you're still looking to eat
perhaps take a second to just recheck
your hunger to make sure that you're not
actually still hungry. If you don't like
the idea of that, you can try putting
your food into leftover containers when
you're done eating, that way you know you
already have it prepped for another meal
and it's visually telling you that your
meal is complete.
Number three - defend yourself from
obligatory eating. Remember that you are
in charge of the type of food and how
much food you eat. If you're not hungry,
you don't have to eat. This is always the
case when visiting a relative's house.
There is always one food pusher who
wants you to eat, and eat, and eat. I mean
we talked all about this in my holiday
food and body shaming video here so you
can check that out. But like I mentioned
in the video, although their intentions
are usually good you have the right to
say no. It's a good thing to just
remember that you do not need to eat
just for the sake of being polite.
Finally, let's address a really common
problem that a lot of people on the
intuitive eating journey have which is
feeling hungry all the time. It may be
frustrating that you're already hungry
after like two hours of eating. You
listened to your hunger and fullness cues,
and yet again here you are hungry.
It's important to keep in mind that there are
a lot of factors that can affect our
fullness. They're both biological and
learned by having a better understanding
of the things that cause us to be hungry
or full. You may also have a better time
trusting your body and actually feeling
your fullness. Here are some factors that
may affect your fullness levels. Number
one - time how much time has passed as the
last time you ate. It sounds obvious, but
the more frequently you eat the less
hungry you end up being. Going too long
between your meals can cause your blood
sugar levels to plummet, your hunger
hormone skyrocketing, and you end up
overeating. If you know that your lunch
and dinner are going to be very far
apart, this is when you'd want to
incorporate some snacks in between.
This allows you to fuel your body and brain
and prevents you from experiencing that
intense hunger. And again, I know this
will be a question "But Abbey, snacking
isn't healthy" and this leads me to my
second point - types of food. Despite
popular belief, snacks are not inherently
unhealthy. But, of course, we can always
make more satiating nutritious choice. So
a snack that is high in healthy fats,
protein, and fiber, will help keep you
full much longer than ones that are just
high in simple sugars. Simple sugars give
you a quick energy boost which is great
certain situations like a high intensity
workout. But without any fiber, protein, or
good fats, it can often be followed by a
rapid crash in blood sugar levels.
This can lead you to feel hungry really soon
after. So if you're noticing that you're
hungry after a snack or meal check in to
see what that meal or snack consisted of.
Ideally you want a meal to have a good
source of protein, fiber from some whole
grains or veggies, and some healthy fats.
I call this the hunger crushing
combination and together these compounds take longer to digest, keeping you
feeling full much longer.
Number three - social influences.
Interestingly, we eat differently
depending on who is around us. In fact,
research suggests that we tend to eat
more food and for much longer when we
eat in large groups. And this makes sense,
if we're by ourselves
we usually just eat our food and move on,
but remember food is a social activity.
So of course, we spend time eating and
chatting and doing all those fun things
when we're with our friends. However,
research suggests that some dieters are
more likely to be influenced by the food
choices of others around them and may
purposefully under eat out of fear being
judged, especially in the presence of
"model eaters". In either situation, we tend
to ignore our biological cues for hunger
and fullness when in front of other people.
My suggestion is to remind yourself that no
one knows your body's needs like you do.
If your friend is having a salad or
barely touches their meal, it may be it's
because they had a big pancake breakfast,
or if another friend is having a burger
and fries or polishes off their plate
and pressures you to do the same, you
never know they maybe skipped breakfast
and are really hungry for a hearty meal.
Everyone's needs are different, so choose
a meal that satisfies your appetite and
make a point to check in with yourself
throughout the meal. Use the social
activity as an opportunity to really
slow down between bites to engage in
conversation and to check in with your
hunger and fullness throughout the meal.
Next, let's talk about "air food". Now a lot
of diet foods are full of air I mean no
literally like a rice cake is full of
air. Hence why I say it's a vessel for
peanut butter in my house but, hey, that's
just me. Now the reason why these
foods are not necessarily the best
snacks on their own is because they only
temporarily decrease hunger. The food
enters your stomach and kind of tricks
you into thinking you're full because it
adds volume but because it's lacking any
real sustenance, you'll be really hungry
pretty quickly. This also can backfire
because these foods tend to have a
health "halo effect". You know that they're
low in calories, so you can eat a large
portion of them to fill your stomach up
but at the end of the day you could have
become full off of a nutrient dense meal
and stayed fuller a lot longer. So a lot
of people, for example, turn to salads as
a healthy option but these too can be
air food, as well. So lettuce in a bowl by
itself is by no means a salad. So here
are some ways to up the staying power of
your salad. First is to add protein, so
things like shredded chicken, tuna,
chickpeas, kidney beans, lentils, and tofu,
are all great options. Also add some
carbs - quinoa, couscous, or have some
whole-grain crackers or bread on the
side. Don't forget about fat as well, so
olive oil, avocado, cheese, nuts, seeds, etc.
Now whether we're talking a salad, or
another meal or snack, the goal here is
to incorporate slow-digesting
macronutrients. So fat, protein, and fibre
rich carbs. Again, we will talk way more
about this in the episode
on gentle nutrition. But bottom line,
becoming aware of fullness factors can
really help your inner food
anthropologist determine the reasons for
your quickly returning hunger. Once
you've determined the cause, you can
slowly incorporate some intuitive eating
principles to work towards feeling your
fullness for much longer. If you feel
like you can't stop eating, even if
you're full, then this may be a sign that
you're using food as a coping mechanism.
I will be diving into this a lot more when
we discuss principle number seven, so
definitely stay tuned for that. Now, your
homework for this week. So this week, I
really want you to focus on eating
consciously. Like I mentioned earlier, I
want you to take a pause a few times
while you're eating really focus on the
flavors of the food, your hunger and
fullness levels, and take charge in
deciding when you're done eating. Find
yourself a visual cue that you can use
to help signal to yourself that you're
done, and be sure to rate your fullness
using that satiety scale. Again, a
reminder that there is no right or wrong
with hunger-fullness scale, just take
notice of where you land before a meal,
during a meal, and after a meal. Jot down
how it makes you feel, what foods you ate,
and how well they helped your hunger.
Continue to work on these steps
throughout your intuitive eating journey,
and of course stay tuned for our next
video on principle number six -
discover the satisfaction factor.  So
folks, that is all for today. If you liked
it be sure to give it a thumbs up, leave
me a comment below if you have any
questions about intuitive eating,
subscribe to the channel, and I will see
you next time on Abbey's Kitchen. Bye!